okay so I completely screwed up that
initial start now I gotta wait for
everyone to find me again so that
started well alright they got everything
think you've got it all uh hi I'm I'm
sorry everybody just yeah this is uh
just kind of one of those days and
things crooked and I'm just gonna live
with it oh thank you rid of this
somebody asked earlier like what's up
with the synced up here it's in a
ponytail because they haven't washed my
hair yet and like I just don't the the
degree that I was prepared to deal with
it is limited everything's stable now I
I bought as stable as it gets with me
okay so as far as the name of the
livestream for this trying UK snacks
this has to do with the I almost said
last batch of stuff that I got for my
birthday but it's probably not because I
probably need to do one more trip to my
peel box to pick up any stragglers but I
was sent a whole bunch of stuff from the
UK that I've never tried before and I
figured you folks can have the treat of
watching me try this stuff still up 3
a.m. oh boy Vienna Austria and also like
I do feel bad because I'm gonna try a
bunch of UK snacks and if you're in the
UK it's 2:00 in the morning right now
sorry but okay
yes Meg it did that oh you know what you
know what something was one of the first
things I got and I have forgotten to
show people this like time after time
after time so let me just sorry give me
a second here
one of the first things that came whoa
dang it didn't get it well
were these mm-hmm sort of 20 little
jeweled elf ears which I love
I think I'm or am I just am I just like
putting it on in a Russian not doing it
well I don't know oh there we go was
like that I'll figure this out oh yeah
that's better so yeah there we go
haha I enjoyed these uh quite a bit uh
Hufflepuff from Reno how are things
today
ah today was uh was a day
I mean well we'll see if I if I got your
package cuz like I said I'm gonna go
through some of the stuff I got it's not
just snacks there is other stuff um but
also I do still need to get to the peel
box for one last one last time have you
had a chance to watch twisted yet no I
need to it's like it's City it's right
here and I know I know I'm like I'm
behind your back you guys are probably
actually gonna get extra videos this
month because I need to try and catch up
I'm a little bit behind us some of the
patreon sponsored reviews and some other
stuff that I have been trying to get
done that I kinda want to get cleared on
my off my plate so that I can I can
start diving into the stuff that's gonna
take me more time oh well so alright so
I got another volume of rat Queens and
volume 3 which which is good because
this one I can actually loan to Liz
because this is the first one that rock
up Church didn't do the art for so
that's awesome that's a woman with a
beard and she is rocking the hell out of
it
I love it uh oh
this god I almost forgot somebody did me
the
and if you can't you can't read it it
says it doesn't matter to whom the
cruelty is directed the cruelty itself
is wrong Sixth Doctor or the Holy Terror
possibly my favorite Doctor Who quote of
all time that was really sweet to get
I'm trying to remember like there was uh
I I'm not organized today there was
stuff that I thought I was gonna talk
about and like I cannot remember what a
lot of it was aside from like going over
gifts and stuff sorry let me get back
here
more council of geeks V this month
doesn't get better than that which is
worse hell-bent or series seven its
hell-bent like series seven is uneven
but it's got some high points in it
would you get a dog or a cat if you had
to I mean I don't know cuz like I'm a
slightly more of a dog person than a cat
person but like with all the stuff
that's going on in my life and
especially a lot of stuff that I travel
for like every time I perform at a
burlesque show that's a weekend I'm away
from home I think I'd I think a dog it's
probably outside of I I couldn't give
the reasonable attention to a dog a cat
I might get away with depending on the
nature of the cat
I suppose my day sucked but at least I
got my ticket Stan yes this seems like a
lot of people did I didn't but it's
because my local rinky-dink Little
Theater doesn't do take us that far in
advance so like I'm not I'm not sweating
it right now are you nervous for
Avengers end game no I'm excited
I I don't have a reason to be nervous
what's your opinion on series eleven
dude I've got video I got whole videos
devoted to my thoughts on series eleven
not gonna take up the time here what
happened to your hair it's just it's
just in a ponytail so nothing happened
to it it's not washed so I didn't feel
like having it in my face I need to take
a shower after this so there you go
Hedwig in the Fez yes I'm glad somebody
caught that I'm fortunate you
really tell like in the normal videos
because the angle of the camera and also
the like how how dark the shadows tend
to be but yeah I I like putting that
there
do you know who ace creeper is I do
indeed know who ace creeper is I enjoy
stuff
let's see Captain Marvel today was
awesome yeah Liss actually said that's
my partner went inside Captain Marvel
read recently and she really liked it
which I was glad to hear um I don't
always know how she's gonna feel about
these sorts of things we tend to line up
but not always so I was glad that she
really she really enjoyed it have you
ever watched the who addicts a little
bit um I it take their stuff runs long
and it's hard for me to nail down which
creators I can sit with for more than
half an hour or honestly more than 15
minutes some at some of the time
and it's I can't like quantify what it
is that makes that the case I do enjoy
the who addicts I like what they do and
or did I guess because they kind of they
kind of decided to stop and and go off
and do other stuff but I I've never like
done a deep dive on them because their
stuff does run a little long for me what
room of the house do you film in I for
some reason that strand like I feel like
that's a personal question even though
it's not really I don't know why it
feels like a personal question I don't
know
all I've got like a weird gut reaction
to that question I don't know why that's
weird okay you know what I got a crack
open some of this stuff so all right
first of all quick question first thing
I'm gonna try people want me to try
something sweet or something salty so
let me know that and then I'll figure
out from there let's see
today I'm also a burlesque er who
produces nerd Lesk shows oh sweet oh
hang it ah I gotta back up I checked out
some of your very last videos I adore
your Wonder Woman number out of
curiosity do you have any doctor who
acts I have two one of which I'm
unlikely to revive again because I it
was a regeneration number this was back
when Matt Smith was still the doctor and
I regenerated into a woman but that's
the novelty of that is kind of gone now
but I do have a thirteenth doctor number
as well which i think is up on drives
and dolls also little buddy got a sweet
salty sweet so oh my god you're just
going back and forth oh heck I'm just
reaching it what's the first thing I'm
hitting all right I've got the real
McCoys ridge cut cheddar and onions
let's see what we got it's an
interesting mix because they're both
flavors that I can kind of go with on
their own
you know the cheddar and the onion and
together they're pretty good it just
sort of takes me a minute like wrap my
head around that I do kind of like see
just seeing it you're written as a
potato crisps makes me feel all
sophisticated that's pretty good
I hate crisps yeah I I try I try not to
eat that kind of stuff because like I
can burn through a really quick and it's
not good for me so I like I do that kind
of stuff I don't keep in the house
because like I'll just snack on it my
own sense of restraint actually isn't
great when it comes to food so the best
thing that I can do is like try and not
just not have certain stuff in the house
it's not because I'm like food allergies
it's just like I know what I'll end up
diving into so crisps are evil they're
the best I believe they are both of
those things
at the same time speaking of McCoy do
you think Sylvester would make a good
Riddler oh that's an interesting
question huh
I mean maybe uh huh don't see why not
have any jelly babies okay you know what
I do but I'm not cracking these open
these get saved for the end what else we
got here oh okay this was a was an
interesting thing that I got sent I got
sent sort of an archived copy of a whole
bunch of Doctor Who novels I'm not gonna
say who sent them because I don't know
the legality of like burning digital
copies of novels onto a disc like this
so not gonna name you don't want to get
anybody in trouble um but that was very
cool uh let's see nearly forgot about
the stream hire from London UK well oh
girl it's two o'clock in the morning
there you should be in bed like I'm glad
you're here thank you but jeez its water
I can't have cookies or anything sugar
in my house if I did I soon weighed 300
pounds I mean that's that's that's kind
of its kind of where where I'm at oh my
god it's Who I am why am i awake uh yeah
what oh boy all right all right let's
get the guy who ever has a adult
beverage at hand you get you drink
anytime somebody asks musics that music
that I like preferred pronouns I gotta
figure out what the other common ones
are we got to make a proper drinking
game out of this and I don't have an
easy answer to that cuz I don't have
like just Yama's of music that I
gravitate towards um have
the three detective style books by Mark
Gatiss I have not I have no restraint
and I've Pringles next to my bed
who that's uh mean whatever gets you
through the night
I suppose what music do you what evil
smile okay now that's cheating and you
know it u.s. snack UK snacks of the
Daleks oh boy
opinion on brexit I do not want to give
an opinion on the concept of the idea
because I don't feel like I have any
business giving an opinion on that the
logistical reality and execution of the
idea I don't think anybody can argue
it's been anything other than a complete
and utter mess I think regardless of
over whether you want or not like I
don't know how anyone could be anything
other than just exasperated infuriated
with like how it's playing out maybe an
faq video you can refer people to oh
that's a thought I don't need sleep yeah
you sound like me you listen to
chameleon circuit or any other truck
music I'm not sure I even know what
truck music is uh Thank You Leon
is spongebob secretly a Dalek
I feel like I've missed something there
okay what else oh my god all right let's
go sweet I have jelly tots I'm not sure
what the deal of these are containing
each 13 sweets contain blah blah blah
blah blah blah blah oh god there's a bad
joke on it what does your nose smell
like I don't know where the answer to
this bad joke is it's just the question
anyways okay let's see I'm gonna assume
this kind of coding my inclination is
sour but let's see nope all right that's
not dissimilar from like say and the US
like like a Mike and Ike just with sort
of a a sugar coating as opposed to a
candy shell so bad and that's so that
that was jelly tots that was hmm
I got a jellies Todd stuck up my nose
when I was 2 had to go to hospital oh
dang
oh you know what was the other thing
that I did that I was gonna that I was
gonna mess around with I think it was
yes dirty yes it was yesterday cuz it
was for April Fool's and I refused to
like actually do pranks cuz pranks are
dumb and mean um so what I did instead
was on Twitter I asked for people to
send me in correct pronunciations for
the Battle of what is it rank or ABS
colos or like I can never remember what
the heck it is but um I'm just gonna I'm
gonna read that I think I got like maybe
20 or so responses so I'm just I'm gonna
try and read some of these without
cracking up we'll see how we do so yeah
here was the original tweet give me some
inventive funny or bizarre
mispronunciations of the Battle of Ren's
cooler I have colos I can start the
burble of rank oars and koalas so that
was my sort of initial prompt ah and
what have we got the Battle of rants
poor as Badou do this is rough the bagel
of rice cakes and croutons can you tell
it's lunchtime the Sorrento ravioli
Alaska Krakatoa continuum the bottle of
rank old colas the barnyard of Mordor of
Croton oh these are fun the Battle of
Rangoon's alla colas I'm feeling that
colas is gonna be a recurring thing here
this Chipotle is rancid and koalas I'm
not good at this
Oh Tim bless your heart the Battle of of
Ricola cooler Yahoo the bottles of
rancid cores and colas the Battle of rum
cores and colas the bibble of rancor and
colos mmm the Battle of rank score of
Calais the bottle of Rinka mm mm hmm
the bottle of wrinkled alpha covers the
Battle of Ratchet and Clank
the bottle of rums cool as cold as cow
laws oh man the babble of rank AV coops
ah the bottle of rancid old Cola there
it is again
the boodle of rents correct Cola deep
demons of the poo jive oh jeez
a bottle of rands kool-aid colors I had
fun with that um
when will you be wearing the David
Dennis style jacket and your doctor who
refused tomorrow because yes it's up in
the closet I was sent a wonderful and
awesome David Tennant coat the outer
coat so that gets its debut in
tomorrow's overdue Doctor Who video so
you have that's a look forward to
the Battle of really ranked coleslaw oh
god they're keeping it going the babble
of the rancor again boy you know for a
desert dwelling creature I imagine that
the rancor would not be happy turning up
in Canada Oh what else we got I'm
realizing I've got way more sweets than
salty here what have I got I've got a
kinder chocolate with cereals it's so
weird it's wheat that like the structure
of that sentence is weird to me with
cereals as an American that sounds
really weird to me
because a cereal to me is a type of food
it's in so like it's like I don't I
don't know how to explain why that
sounds weird I'll be like I don't know a
chocolate with sugars like ends that
doesn't sound quite right so let's see
see what's interesting about the UK
sweets and I remember this from my visit
at London - they're generally less
aggressively sugary and aggressively
sweet than us tends to be so in an
American chocolate bar the I'm gonna
call them what I know them as the sort
of rice krispies type things that are in
it would have been texture and nothing
else because they would just been
overpowered with sugar and chocolate
um whereas this I can actually taste
them as a flavor instead of just have
them as a texture so that's uh that's
interesting I'll have some cereals and
milk for breaky mum am i British
about as well as I could I'm sure kinder
is German no I mean possibly I don't
know
I'm an American I don't know squat uh
what about the pin night in pinstripe
suit you have a responsibility to okay
look the pinstripe suit is on order I
was given cash for my birthday I ordered
the suit but I ordered it you know in in
custom sizing so it takes longer to get
here I'm supposed to get it later this
month
I don't know when goodness sake I love
her Lee were Lee's Brits helped me out
break key that's not how you say it yeah
I'm sure it isn't like I don't come to
me for correct pronunciation of anything
I know we stopped reacting to overdo Who
but I'm still watching I stopped doing
them because feeling obligated to talk
about it took it out of me yeah
lightened I feel you on that like when
something becomes more of a chore than
something that you enjoy
you know that's usually a good time to
stop doing it especially if like
it's you don't need to it's not your
living so choice the Battle of British
breakfast don't know how to spell
brekkie yeah well what can you do that's
it did I miss the jelly babies nah I'm
saving the jelly babies I have the jelly
babies they're getting saved we're gonna
end there we build to that um what else
have I got here
oh all right some other stuff I was said
I got sent to murder the the reboot one
the first one for uh for ps3 which is
the most recent gaming console I have I
am excited to try this out I actually I
was never a huge fan of the original
tomb raiders large eek I do I hated the
way she controlled I could never get her
to behave consistently the way I wanted
to which now that I say that sounded god
that's a sentence I really hope never
gets clipped and they get out of context
cuz that sounded awful um but uh I don't
know what I'm gonna get to this like I
have so many games that I just don't
know when the heck I'm gonna get to so
what else we got here okay
we got I got mini eggs
chok chok cakes what that doesn't roll
off the tongue all right I am gonna have
to bust out the the other the other
salty ones soon all right actually you
know what let's cleanse slightly with
the the cheddar and onion tank controls
an old tomb raider gamers were bad tank
controls were the worse there is no such
thing as good tank controls that was a
horrible way to control a character in a
game
let's see okay oh all right that's
interesting
hmm
should've known it was gonna have the
cream thing go on because it's Cadbury
it's not that far out of the realm of
things like like Little Debbie here in
the states it's actually pretty akin to
it it's good but this is the kind of
thing that I can't have a lot of just
because like Mike my tolerance for sweet
has gone down as I've gotten over older
and just it just kind of like cloyingly
sweet like feels like it sticks in my
throat these days did you get mark did
you get Seth Marmite no no I did not
and from what I understand about Marmite
I'm like kind of glad it kind of scares
me same with Vegemite for that matter I
want to go to Japan solely for the
unique Kit Kat flavors I've heard about
some of those
it was our interesting okay Oh somebody
actually sent me a collection of stories
called critical mass and other stories
that actually has I believe if I
understood the note that came with it
correctly the actually some stories by
the person who sent it to me so that I
am I'm looking forward to getting into
it again like so much of these things I
don't know when I'll get to like twisted
it like I keep meaning to and I don't
get to it oh you know what I have done
those I I can't remember if I mentioned
this before I have actually now been
listening to trans gender dysphoria
blues cuz they've got it in the car and
I'm enjoying it quite a bit so that's
nice and awesome had fun well somebody
else will sent me the soundtrack to
Buffy the Vampire Slayer like like the
generals score so I've got that my car
now too and that's very cool but like
books like I'm
yeah one of the patreon sponsor reviews
I'm behind on is a book that I was
supposed to have to review up last month
I am right now I'm just kind of busting
my butt trying to get it ready for this
month because I feel really bad that I
haven't had it up yet so as far as
reading those that's that's my my top
priority
are you seen poor Japanese Kit Kats the
US when I had a real job but I can't
afford it anymore
I I would imagine that's a bit of an
expense expensive habit took a break
from a live stream to check out Doctor
Who burlesque loved the choice of music
in the choreography for the thirteenth
doctor number and you're adorable in the
eleventh Doctor number thank you that
thirteenth doctor number was actually
that was interesting is that what that
was a departure for me that was um for
lack of a better term much more
dancer-ly than I usually am because I
tend to choreograph fairly loosely I
don't have a dance background so but
that so that had a very different vibe
from what I usually do but I was really
happy with the with the end results on
that um I found green tea Kit Kats in
Japanese corner store in New York City
hmm
have you been to the UK I have I was in
London from a honeymoon back in 2007
yeah 2007 I was there so twelve years
ago I had a lot of fun there do you
watch many channels that don't do pop
culture related stuff um trying to think
now of what I watch no that's that's the
vast majority of what I watch is is pop
culture related in some way axis of
awesome did a great cover of trans
gender dysphoria blues after Jordan came
out as trans oh cool
2007 back huh back when Martha was a
companion
yes and like I've told this story before
I'll just do it real quick I got into
doctor because of my honeymoon because
my my daughter's mother she she went to
take a bath and I flipped through
channels and I came across the Satan pit
and I stopped on an ood because it
reminded me it made me think of a mind
flayer from from D&D so and that was the
first bit of Doctor Who I watched and I
got back to the Saints and thought I
need to check out more of this and
that's why I'm a Doctor Who fan well
thank you very much meg wouldn't would
you want to see the we will rock you
musical it's going on tour in the States
near the end of the year I want to see
it myself I haven't heard of that so I'm
not entirely sure what it is like I'm
gonna sue me as something Queen related
based off the name but I'm I don't
really know and I hadn't heard of that
buuuut are my favorite alien species
I don't they're my favorite alien
species I like the design on them though
quite a bit which episodes of Futurama
are better the ones on Fox or Comedy
Central ah
honestly I think can go either way
there's a different vibe to them they
got a bit more experimental in on Comedy
Central
whereas they were a bit more sort of
joke focused on Fox um but I mean
they're both good it's just a it's just
a shift
have you gone to potted Potter nope not
even sure what that is okay oh man
there's there's so much stuff that like
people ask me about and I'm like oh god
somebody asks what music do you like
alright everybody take a shot oh it's a
Queen's songbook musical okay I guess I
could've guessed that um I mean sounds
like it could be good I mean if you've
got people that can actually sing it
like Queen is not easy to sing have you
ever played an April Fool's joke on
someone not that not like seriously like
like when I was in grade school like
stew
but not centered your shoes untied but
like I've never been like I don't like
pranks
I just don't practical jokes
I think are awful I did just awful I
hate them I don't like watching them
I don't like participating with them I
hate having them happen to me I almost
beat the crap out of out of a suitemate
in in college for for pulling a prank on
me like seriously I pushed him up
against the wall I almost decked him
so yeah nah not a fan good you know your
eyebrows was taking one of the kitties
around why do we feel like someone just
was just looking for something to make a
gif out of and yes his pronounce gif
don't argue with me I don't have any
drinks near me right now hate when
people pretend to be pregnant as a joke
do people still do that is that like
still a thing I felt like we got over
that long but yeah for April Fool's my
older brother convinced our little
sister she was a vampire she stabbed me
that I was a vampire she stabbed me in
the leg with a wooden stake huh man last
time I got pranked some will put my name
under the lead for a fast and for a fake
cast list for Joseph and the Amazing
Technicolor Dreamcoat look that no no
that's funny like what I hate about
pranks is like what I like about jokes
are the kinds of jokes that I like is
they require a certain amount of
cleverness oh you know a twisting of
words a twisting of an idea in a new and
unique way pranks are just being mean
they're making someone feel awful for
whatever reason whether it's because you
just make them feel awful about
something or you make them feel good
about something and then tear it away
that's cruel I don't I don't get it I
don't
you know someone else is in the gift not
Jeff camp well of course it's it's it's
an acronym the G stands for graphic you
don't say traffic it's graphic it's gay
its gif it's gotta be gift it's about a
people about a group of people called
Bohemians who fight for music and
freedom of fashion and speech to be
allowed in the in a future where
everyone is the same oh all right I
gotta look this thing up it's that
interesting
pranks are basically glorified bullying
no they're just bullying under a
different name I'm not even gonna give
them the dignity of calling them
glorified okay now we're gonna get to
something that I'm gonna be honest I am
terrified so this this is McCoys
sizzling king prawn oh god okay oh boy
like I hate seafood I got hate it so the
idea of something flavored to taste like
seafood
but isn't okay oh Jesus
oh that's a No
oh that's a hard no oh jeez
haha the exact reaction I was expecting
oh man oh that was a prank on you well
yeah but that the difference is though I
suspected what was happening there so
I'm not sure it counts as a prank cuz
it's not like it was like oh this'll
taste awesome like I knew what I was
getting into for that do you have a way
to listen to some of the missing Doctor
Who episode soundtracks I use audible
that's the cheapest way of found I
haven't really looked into it because I
haven't I haven't really like delved
into into finding the ones that have
like no video component at all yet so
that's a that's something that I'll I'll
bridge that gap eventually I apologize
for the shrimp one wasn't sure to be
honest it's okay Meg I just I hope you
feel you got your money's worth I'm in
Marilyn and old BAE's chips aren't my
favorite ah all right like I the cheddar
and onions good like I'm gon palate
cleansing with those have you seen any
star kid musicals like Amy p.m. or
twisted no but I have twisted it was
sent to me
and I haven't watched it yet it was sent
to me a little while ago actually
you missed earlier when the person who
sent it asked him I think it was the
person who's then it has if I watched it
at this point like the regular people on
the stream know that I have it so I
can't even keep track of whether it's
the person who originally sent it who's
asking or whether it's just people now
bugging me because they know I've been
slacking so far
all right oh yeah I got Maynard's
Behcet's
wine gums mocktails okay I didn't really
look at this bag very carefully
carefully three flavors strawberry
daiquiri pina colada and Cuba Libre I'm
not I don't even know what's gonna cue
believe right okay what are we still
let's try if you like pina coladas
[Music]
actually I kind of like gummy stuff
anyway it's got a good consistency too
because like some some gummies are just
like way too dang soft that's a turn-off
for me they gotta have a good that they
need to have a bounce to them they need
they need though they need to fight a
little they need to fight me destroying
them try strawberry daiquiri it's not
bad you know what I'm immediately
curious about though is if you were to
say soak those in the actual alcoholic
beverage for a while like how how would
that go like if you if you made some
equivalent of jell-o shots with them
losing this thing ah oh god there's a
fight going on now oh boy
like my favorite comings are I've
forgotten the brand name but there's
cinnamon cinnamon gummy bears huh sorry
I didn't mean to bug you I just didn't
know what scares no no don't worry about
it
like when I say that something gets
asked right here leave I'm not mad at
you for asking like I know people come
in and out of the live stream it's like
you may not have been in one before like
hey it's fine was the letter I sent
legible yes Meg yes it was
cuz either they you say your
handwriting's bet my handwriting my my
seven year-olds handwriting is about it
on par with mine she's gonna end up
better than better than mine by next
year I'm sure my handwriting is
atrocious
Oh on the L got them the gift chip thing
is still going on I was gift for years
settled the debate with a friend we
agreed to go with him what the creator
said the creator said it was jiff
now I'm honorbound to say jiff to heck
with honor jiff sounds dumb Jeff is a
brand of peanut butter yeah sometimes
you sacrifice your honor to not sound
like a [ __ ]
thank you for the eyebrows because you
do with your face in profile or three
words okay look there's only so much of
a trained monkey that I'm prepared to be
Haribo star me haribol haribol makes
very good gummies okay what else did I
hear I did that I did that oh I have oh
good Oh gum man I forgot got sent some
stuff from the folks who do the Renard
City chronicles which included more so
than others
this isn't UK but whatever whatever guy
here homeboy it's more sweets so I've
got one thing that I know what it is and
one thing that I don't so what have I
got
I've got nah salty caramel and peanuts
that seems like one things one thing too
many cuz I do like salted caramel I
don't know if you need peanut with that
but let's see how that is I'll get to
those jelly babies don't worry
it's kind of what I'm talking about
before which is that I mean there's
peanuts in it you can see them but the
pieces are so small I never really I get
like a vague background of peanuts I
never really feel like I get a nut
it's mostly just the chocolate and
salted caramel flavor I'm dying to try
cannabis candy edibles are becoming a
pretty big thing actually in Vermont I
have more than a few friends who indulge
in edibles
I haven't I I I'm trying not to talk
with my mouth full I have a fair amount
of paranoia about certain substances
that it's not really worth getting into
excessively but yeah hoping I can stay
here blowing up see the jelly babies I
tell you what in five minutes we'll do
the jelly babies what I need to figure
out is this thing because this has this
tiny thing that says warp king mystery
flavor and I can't help but be nervous
on anything that touts itself as mystery
flavor so what prompted this stream well
I mean I do a live stream every Tuesday
and somebody has sent me a care package
with a whole bunch of um of snacks so
that's the that's what prompted the
theme but the the live stream is a
regular thing huh boy ooh
that's an odd smell
almost smells like a aiya scented candle
I'm not even sure what it is it's not ah
not even sure it's awful but it's it's
incredibly artificial whatever it is
like the like the base is white
chocolate I can tell that from the
consistency I'm not sure what the
flavoring is but it's just really really
artificial um yeah I'm not oh I'm not
sure what's going on there
I really hope that that the person who
said that that it wasn't like their
favorite thing ever that they're really
hoping I love cuz I'll feel like a
jackass but Moo
alright let's get another cheddar and
onion too much pink energy is dangerous
so mystery flavor or shrimp chips oh if
you were gonna make me take a second
bite of something I might do a second
bite of the prawn chips before the
mystery flavor again I still wouldn't
like it but like haha I'm not gonna do
either there's such a thing as too much
pink energy
well that's it's it's a slight meme I
think it's uh I mean I know it from
Linkara cuz he uses it's a it's a Power
Rangers reference I think
damn cuz that was such a visceral
reaction to the project well this is the
the prawn chips were just so immediately
off-putting but like there was something
about that candy that like crept up on
me and like it's still there like I
actually the prawn chips not good but I
felt like I could cleanse those out of
my system pretty quickly like that's
holding on whatever the heck that was of
all the doctors had to fight who would
win attack eyebrows would win seafood
for life no no no seafood no sir what's
your favorite food do you like favorite
dish is homemade macaroni and cheese cuz
I'm a nostalgic bugger war would win I
mean you say that but I haven't I need
to get into more of the more doctor
stuff before I feel like I could make
that call seafood is good and pineapple
on pizza is sin block oh oh
meg those are fighting words on both
counts my goodness
alright so jelly babies that's how boy
don't know what to make of that so like
I looked on the back hoping to see
flavors and it shows me the different
colors and there are things under it but
they're not flavors apparently there's
names for each of these so the red is
brilliant the yellow is bubbles the pink
is baby Bonnie green is buthe holes
oranges bumper purple is big heart no
indication of what the flavors actually
are Hilda's been nominated for four
Daytime Emmys oh cool like I see how
much I connected with my daughter kind
of warmed me to that
show a bit more are you cleansing your
palate with vodka Oh actually you know
what speaking of stuff I have sitting
around
ah all right yeah there you get my butt
for a bit um I love your channel don't
have it don't hate me I don't hate you
make actually good I had this I got this
in my stocking at Christmas blue
raspberry vodka so uh so now I'm
Jonathan fair I do I try jelly baby
first I'd yeah well come back to the
vodka oh boy to care for a jelly baby oh
jeez okay first of all like I find this
a little unsettling I'm pretty sure he's
crying he's like got his hand up and I'm
gonna eat like that's putting me off a
little bit what
I'm trying to decide what I think of
that I had a good smoke job goes for the
alcohol yeah that's pretty much my life
it's like think that was a green that's
the other thing like the colors are oh
good this one's got like a big pooch
tout stomach but the colors are muted in
such a way as to also be a little bit
off-putting like oh wow huh
you know what's the the vibe I get off
this the vibe I get off this is like
maybe folks in the US will get this
reference
it's like Necco wafers not that not that
I'm making a direct comparison between
the taste but like in the sense that
they taste very old-fashioned it it
tastes like something that was created a
long time ago and has not been in any
way updated streamlined that's that's
kind of the the vibe I get off these I'm
gonna try one more
what was this orange this one's holding
something it's not a belt or is like he
holding a bottle that's a very big smile
I'm gonna say it's a bottle like the the
design on these I find very
disconcerting
uh yeah I'm like I'll keep them around
for the Doctor Who reference but not
loving them be honest which is a sheep I
would have liked to have but now
Tom Baker started not to like them
anymore they switch to licorice
good call Tom Baker wait a minute what
I'm sorry I'm just just sees somebody
going CW four out of my what did I just
walk in on like what what happened in
the chat while I was while I was focused
on jelly jelly babies
and the winner is cheddar and onion
chips yes actually that is the winner um
I finished a good place on your
recommendation I know you love seasons
wanted to some thoughts on season three
I like that a lot too I don't I don't
know if I have a favorite season I've
loved that I second one might be my
favorite I do like all of them
and the third season has my single
favorite moment which is from Jeremy
bury me when GD breaks I love that so
much I've got to say since you came out
on this channel last year I felt much
more comfortable commenting and joining
in these chats thank you that is yay
that is wonderful to hear like if if my
being more visible at all makes
anybody's life like a little bit easier
that that's kind of everything to me
like I'm dead yes
dang it yes hopefully that episode wins
the who go yes Hugh Award nominations
round two Doctor Who episodes are up
Rosa and demon of the Punjab and also
two good place episodes Jeremy Berra me
and Janice which was also very good
Haribo jelly babies are way better I
mean hair bow just makes gummy bears or
at least that's what I'm used to so you
know what I am gonna crack open the blue
raspberry vodka
it's fedka yeah that's that's the real
sign of quality vodka holy cow pregnant
open this door thing are you familiar
with Jim khattak aka kid icarus actually
I'm not not familiar okay this is
bugging me now
ah ,
yes son of up ah you will not hide from
me booze I turned it to General Zod or
something I will find him there we go
oh oh oh that is artificial raspberry if
I ever smelled it ah like the the funny
thing is raspberry might well be my
favorite fruit certainly my favorite
berry but our official raspberry flavor
can really go either way sometimes
almost done for the night just hang on a
few yeah I'm wrapping up soon I mean
that's why all right Cheers
wha-wha-wha-what was the proof on that I
should check that first 70 okay it's not
Oh Dan ah there we are
uh who is the best doc in Doctor Who you
know actually I've I've reached the
conclusion that my favourites Capaldi
and like I've waffled on that before but
I I've actually kind of settled on that
for right now sudden transformation into
water he also moved down that in three
seconds look I I don't mess around like
this I can deal with this so I'll get it
over with
can't pay for that kind of entertainment
oh wow yeah I guess I did turn into
Wario there for a second but this doctor
is 8 and 12 solid picks both you just
became my best friend for saying that
Capelli's my doctor are you ending this
soon just tuned in well I mean like
normally I run about an hour where
should give me a few minutes left I mean
it's not a hard cutoff I can I might
stick around a little longer than that
but um you know I'm not gonna say I'm
super late cuz like I've got um I needed
to take a shower
I've got editing to do so and I mean I
know it's super late for somebody who
people who are here so I feel bad if
you're like staying up with me um
compiled he was good felt too short
though yeah like in an odd way his
tenure felt shorter than it was which I
like I'll agree it felt that way but he
it wasn't really it was weird 5 a.m.
good grief where are you 3 a.m.
yeah I mean it's about a 3 a.m. in the
UK now
for dode 4 a.m. oh my gosh
Russia is like that holy cow new to the
channel well welcome Amelia 11 is mine
oh I was really big on a living for a
while I think what I loved about 11
especially at the time it was airing
Matt Smith was what was is my age so
there was something about seeing add
seeing a doctor who was the same age as
me and be like oh I could be the doctor
well I kind of made me appreciate him
quite a bit at at the time he doesn't
like really dropped in my estimation
just others have kind of risen higher as
time has gone on 9:00 a.m. in Vietnam
okay so I mean that's that's a decent
start to the morning wasn't expecting a
anyone from Vietnam but you know I like
the the reach of this channel astonishes
me sometimes like legitimately I mean
I'm looking at this at this here's a
hundred and twenty people extended up
watching me try snacks this is this is
surreal in like the best way Planet of
the geeks Saudi Arabia Vietnam Ireland
oh man are you are you claiming me I
have something better to do look I don't
know I'm not gonna judge if you don't
that's fine if you do well you chose to
watch me so cool in my book all right
you know what Meg just for you
for your edification one more let's just
see if that initial reaction was a
complete fluke
Oh nope there it is ah oh yeah I take it
back
those are worse than that then that
weird chocolate was I think the only
reason I thought that was worse at the
time was cuz I couldn't pinpoint what
the deal was but no those are worse I'm
sorry
ah man imagine during an Avengers
endgame there's a huge fight scene and
everyone is about to die that we hear
the TARDIS what's in the bottle the
bottle was just water that's my story
and I'm sticking to it what do you think
about a Doctor Who Sherlock crossover
like I almost feel like that's too
obvious to be completely honest no water
in quotes my puppy is watching he who
intently puppy approved yes that is my
target demographic small dogs are we
really sure it isn't vodka well if this
was vodka I'd have a very serious
problem because this was full when I
started and I've just splashed a little
into my lap so maybe you had a point
I think a Halloween special would be
brilliant
well for me or for Doctor Who firewater
Doctor Who versus Doctor Strange I want
them to fight but I would love to see
them argue I would love to see the
doctor get into an argument with dr.
strange over time to travel
no slurring Day Giveaway
yeah no I'm totally sober I'm fine it's
just been great that t-shirt the ad yeah
I mean I do like this t-shirt quite a
bit how much do we need to pay on
patreon for a drunk livestream oh I
don't I don't know like here's the thing
like the reason I do these on Tuesdays
is because it's the only day that I can
reliably fit in my schedule here's what
I would say to a to the idea of a
drinking livestream I'm not opposed to
it if I ever did it it wouldn't be on
the regular Tuesday would have I would
have to be like a Friday or a Saturday
or something something where I wouldn't
have to get up in the morning to go to
work
and then like I'd want to think of
something to do other than just drink so
like the one time the one time on this
channel that I have gotten drunk was
watching the premiere episode of the
Inhumans because I had to there was no
other way I was gonna get through that
thing so like I I'm not I don't have it
in me just to sit and drink I need to be
sitting drinking and like doing
something so like maybe I don't know
start a Kickstarter to to have me do a
drunk livestream we'll see what we get
tipsy Q&A oh boy
that huh I would worry about that both
both in terms of the questions I would
get if people knew I was not sober and
how I would answer them everyone
involved would be drunk if overage yes
of course always be responsible I I
wanted the Inhumans to work son of M
storyline NMC you like the Inhumans was
such a like it's Scott buck was involved
it was never gonna work here do a great
channel a great person keep being cool
Thank You Gabe thank you very much so
yeah I do think I am gonna wrap it up I
got a oh man I've got all these open
things now I gotta figure out which of
these will keep which I can reseal which
I just need to toss take those crisps
those are not getting saved holy cow
be drunk for when Dark Phoenix comes out
all right I'll tell you what once I
figure out when I'm going to see Dark
Phoenix I will consider I'm not gonna
promise but I will consider coming on
for a live stream for uncensored
uncensored drinking thoughts on what I
expect is a disaster of a movie not
promising that but I'm gonna consider it
dark feet yeah dark fears is gonna be a
mess I'm so unbelievably happy right now
that is great to hear magum oh by
driving a good night um you sound like a
dad I am a dad like what are people
still surprised by that like is that
still news for some folks that I'm a
parent I guess I did god I I did slip
into dad boys a bit there didn't I
um will you see Shazam I don't know like
whether or not I see Shazam is basically
gonna be is it convenient for me if it's
something that like I have to go out of
my way to see or it's a pain in the butt
to fit in my schedule I might wait until
like streaming or rental or something
because like I'm not pumped for it I'm
sure it'll be fine
it's just I'm looking at the trailer
going I don't think that's gonna be for
me ah
have you read Magnus chase and the gods
of Asgard I have not I am I'm aware of
it but no no I have not there's
something back here that I've missed oh
I lost it Wow whatever
young justice season three is better
than the DC movies haven't seen that can
you do dad jokes like I could but I'm a
little bit too much respect for that
self respect that is curious on your
opinion on Alexandra ships recent
remarks I neither know who that is or
what they said so no review for us us is
not playing within 50 miles of where I
live I am ticked off by that fact I want
to see that movie sobered I'm like
legitimately irritated at this point yes
I did know about the gender-fluid
character in the magnus chase books how
do you feel about visual novel games
like I played them a little like when I
was in college
not really my my bag I think yeah I
think I think I'm gonna I'm gonna wrap
it up so yeah thanks for joining me
folks Thank You Meg and anyone else to
sent me stuff
hope you enjoyed it hope you had fun
next week
think in my head next week is going to
be seven o'clock Eastern Time I had to
do nine three weeks in a row normally I
do nine seven nine seven but I had to do
nine last week as well which made it
three in a row next week will be 7 p.m.
Eastern Time so come on back then it's a
more reasonable hour if you're in the UK
but hope everybody has a great night
thanks for joining me you're all awesome
you survived April